Biden incorporated Biden Inc has been
exposed the cloud of corruption darkens
above Joe 303 300 shady family business
dealings and we have big bombshell news
that the media mob doesn't want you to
know about now to any American with a
functioning brain it could not be any
more obvious what's going on here that
that is that this family profited off
his diplomacy in Ukraine and in China
and even as the media mob is doing
everything in their power to try and
cover for them and suspend any fidelity
to truth well now we have outlined on
this show night after night Joe is son's
shady dealings in Ukraine we're sleepy
creepy crazy Uncle Joe leverage your tax
dollars to get a prosecutor fired now
why would any Vice President of the
United States ever involve himself in
such a thing but as bad as Joe's
bragging on tape is that was just mere
millions that's all but the bigger the
much brighter spotlight now shines on
the Communist Chinese we're a hunter
Biden received a sweetheart billion
dollar later billion and a half dollar
deal just days after traveling with his
father on Air Force two these are the
facts as we have now known them we
rewind we go back to December 2013 on
our Biden he joined his father on Air
Force two on a trip to China where his
father had a meeting with the Chinese
president then in December 2013
literally less than two weeks later
honor Biden's company inked a 1 billion
dollar private equity deal with a
subsidiary of the Chinese government's
Bank of China and as Peter Switzer
outlined two pointed out in secret
empires the number one bestseller this
was a deal unlike any other Western firm
got and it went to Hunter Biden who far
as we can tell had zero expertise in
China or private equity now it's white
uruk's white sir explains quote in short
the Chinese government was literally
funding a business that is co-owned
along with the sons of two of America's
most powerful decision-makers
Bank of China that's not your average
bank that's not like Chase Citibank no
it is a powerful tool controlled by the
Communist Chinese by Beijing they have
the ability to wield tremendous
political power honor Biden and others
cashed in despite seemingly having no
qualifications no experience now ABC
apparently interviewed hunter Biden we
will find out more tomorrow it should be
interesting to hear what he has to say
let's see how he deals with questions
hopefully that he gets about having no
experience and flying over to China and
Air Force two and ten days later
basically saying yeah the the Chinese
bank and the Bank of China they picked
me over let's say Oh Bain Capital
goldman sachs deutsche bank you know the
real pros at this because it looks like
panic may be setting in now if you're
putting the Biden's in all-out damage
control at this hour because hunter is
now finally breaking his silence I kind
of bet any amount of money that has
probably been a lot of preparation going
on behind the scenes I'm just guessing
years of experience in this business
thirty one of them tells me that
probably happened we'll find out about
that too and time in addition to sitting
down for an interview with ABC News he
also announced Wow his a resignation
from a Chinese back private equity
company saying through his lawyer that
if his father becomes president well he
won't serve on any foreign board boards
at all it's a little bit late because he
was doing it when his father was vice
president in countries that he was going
to and working on behalf of this country
for but it doesn't answer any of the
fundamental questions does it now is ABC
they're gonna ask some of the basic
fundamental questions or give him a
softball interview I don't know well
they asked the specifics of Biden's work
and Ukraine in China well they asked
specifically what he did for all this
money
what were his actual day-to-day job
duties well they asked what
qualifications he had well they asked if
his status as the son of America's
second most powerful decision-maker was
a factor in the sweetheart deal why not
pick let's see
Bain Capital Goldman Sachs Deutsche Bank
or any
the big firms with tons of experience
now let's also play our little game
let's replace the name VP Joe Biden with
VP Donald Trump even though the
president would not like that demotion
and will replace the name hunter with
the name Don Jr what do you think would
happen especially with the media mom
what if Don jr. were taking millions of
dollars from one country shady oil deals
no experience in the country or that
industry at all and then billions
billion and a half to be exact from the
Bank of China after flying with his
father was vice president on Air Force
two and Don jr. at zero experience with
either country and by the way zero
experience in any of businesses that are
paying him you actually think the mob
and the media they'd be saying this is a
conspiracy theory or a hoax or do you
think that they're endless breathless
hysteria and reporting would go on for
months and months on end because also
developing tonight the Democrats
politically motivated unconstitutional
impeachment charade is unraveling before
their eyes and even Adam the cowardly
shifty shifty is backtracking tonight
making the major admission that maybe
the non whistleblower whistleblower
well apparently his team coordinated
with well doesn't have to testify at all
and that he should have been more clear
about a secret contact in his office's
contact with the non whistleblower
whistleblower in the first place G
replaced shift with the name Trump and I
wonder if the media would accept this
crap
take a look we were interested in having
the whistleblower come forward our
primary mark well our primary interest
right now is making sure that that
person is protected
indeed now there's more than one
whistleblower that they are protected
and given that we already have the call
record we don't need the whistleblower
who wasn't on the call to tell us what
took place during the call we have the
best evidence of that it may not be
necessary to take steps that might
reveal the whistleblowers identity to do
that and we're going to make sure we
protect that whistleblower
I doubt the media would give Trump a
pass with that flimsy answer by the way
the president just weighed in tweeting
quote shifty shift now seems to think
they
I need the whistleblower who started the
whole scam yeah because they're gonna
find out about the relationship with
let's see shifties office and they're
gonna have to deal with the fact that we
don't need any whistleblower non
whistleblower anyway
yeah because actually have the
transcript and maybe it's time for
Republicans in the Senate in the house
maybe they need to go on record with a
very simple statement that that
transcript does not in any way rise to
any level of impeachable offense let's
get that on the table so that they can
know ahead of time that this witch-hunt
not going to go on for three years like
their last witch-hunt went on and by the
way the real reason the whistleblower
non whistleblower has lost all
credibility because the story is so far
from the facts of the actual transcript
we don't need the interpretation of
somebody that got the information visa
vie hearsay you're starting to notice a
theme corruption hypocrisy lies deceit
in the Democratic Party and their allies
in the media mob every accusation they
make every attack every smear every
allegation is nothing more than
projection remember shift said we've not
spoken directly to the whistleblower
when in fact his office did in fact have
direct contact with the individual
before he ever filed the complaint
apparently he was advised by that team
to get a lawyer file a complaint with
the inspector general another in other
words that would be an organized
political hit job from the get-go and
according to the Washington Examiner
tonight we're now learning the fake
whistleblower is quote professional ties
to Joe Biden shocker and it's Democrats
they're the ones guilty of real
collusion corruption with Ukraine
they're the ones guilty of conspiracy
just like ship is the only one that I
know on tape thinking he's speaking to a
Russian digging up dirt on Donald Trump
and of course compromising materials and
naked tadam but and all that and
vladimir of course vladimir knows the
other ones and it's them to leveraging
US tax dollars in a quid pro quo an
obvious shakedown with our money to fire
let's see a prosecutor in ukraine and
literally working in ukraine according
to Politico January 11 2017
yeah the Ukrainians they worked on
Hillary's behalf for that election and
they screwed up they picked the wrong
horse they're the ones that weaponized
intelligence to spy on the Trump
campaign they're the ones that use
Russian lies to influence the 2016
election and then to spy on a candidate
and a transition team and then later a
president and by the way that's them
it was reaction to all this Fox News
contributor investigative reporter Sarah
Carter all right you look at this all
it's now like boomerangs everywhere it
all comes back to them but it's true if
you replace the name Trump with Biden I
think we get a very different reaction
from the corrupt media well they would
be dragged through the mud the way they
are already being dragged through the
mud on false stories Sean all you have
to do is see how the evidence is pouring
out against them the boomerang as you
say it wasn't only that the
whistleblowers story just didn't add up
Adam Schiff and the whistleblower
himself did not inform the intelligence
community's Inspector General Michael
Atkinson that they had communicated that
he basically was in communication with
Adam shifts committee on this and had
requested help from the committee before
submitting the complaint and now we find
out that of course whoa lo and behold
the whistleblower worked for Joe Biden
in the past and that they did admit to
the Inspector General that they did work
for a prominent Democrat they did know
that so what we're seeing here is a
continuous cover-up
this is the reason why Adam Schiff
doesn't want the whistleblower actually
to come forward he wants to push this
aside now we know there was no quid pro
quo there was absolutely no quid pro quo
because we know now from President
szalinski of Ukraine that he had no idea
that any military aid was being withheld
prior to speaking with President Trump
and even after he just had no idea and
if you just look at the transcript on
its face which was eventually released
by the president you can see that for
yourself so now of course Schiff on Face
the Nation
it's trying to find a way to cover up
for this but remember this and this is
something that I've been talking to
sources on Capitol Hill about Schiff is
continuing to push continuing to push
over and over again for some type of
impeachment and this is moving forward
as an impeachment investigation I just
don't think the American people are
gonna buy these lies anymore I will tell
you if they do we will lose this great
Republic they don't you know question to
Ben Franklin how I proposed my monarchy
or Republic Republic if you can keep it
let's see if we can keep this one